hi guys it's me quinn and as always if
you appreciate my content consider
hitting the like button it's the only
way the youtube algorithm really notices
me
galactic civilizations have long been a
staple of science fiction
humankind's transition from the egg that
is the earth into the realm of space
just seems like a natural evolution
as civilization grows more resources are
required
space has infinite resources and the
earth itself is fragile
if something catastrophic ever happened
all of humankind would be put at risk
spreading into the reaches of space
would prevent this
a galactic civilization not only seems
like a logical step
it's perhaps a necessary one
still as they are depicted in science
fiction galactic empires do indeed seem
to possess a number of key problems
the first problem is communication
if humanity is spread throughout space
on different planets then conventional
methods of communication would not be
practical
inhabitable planets could be light years
away from one another without the
ability to communicate efficiently no
form of galactic government could exist
and human cosmic society would be no
more than a collection of planets
operating mainly independent of each
other the solution to such a problem
would of course be technological
innovation which is the approach of most
science fiction
in the dune saga instantaneous
communication is possible through utes
of the holtzman effect the holtzman
effect is a fictional scientific
phenomenon discovered by abraham von
holtzmann according to the dune
encyclopedia it allowed for
instantaneous communication between
distant worlds similarly in dan simmons
hyperion cantos communication between
worlds is possible through use of fat
line technology the worlds had to be
previously set up with fatline
technology infrastructure beforehand
worlds connected in this method also had
the capability to allow for access to
the all thing essentially an advanced
form of the internet
fatline technology had been gifted to
humanity by the techno core and only
they had an intimate understanding of
how exactly the technology worked
sixteen law's remembrance of earth's
past trilogy
solves the problem of communication with
technology involving the phenomenon of
quantum entanglement
this method unlike the one appearing in
dune hyperion and in most other science
fiction series is actually based upon
real scientific principles
quantum entanglement is also sometimes
referred to as the quantum non-local
connection is a property of a quantum
mechanical system
in which two particles can be linked
together in such a way that one cannot
be described without full mention of its
counterpart this is true regardless of
the particle's physical distance from
each other in the universe
the next problem is commerce and travel
similarly to the problem of
communication commerce and travel would
be necessary for a galactic society to
function it's practical to assume that
some worlds would possess resources that
others did not some would be
agriculturally oriented some would be
worlds rich in natural resources and
precious metals
if trade between worlds is not possible
then there really is no cosmic
civilization at all for trade is a
fundamental aspect of all civilization
if humans cannot travel between worlds
in a reasonable amount of time it would
be near impossible for any kind of
interplanetary culture to develop
in the dune universe the time before the
guild whose navigators could navigate
the vacuum of space was a dark age after
the fall of the machines mankind could
no longer move safely throughout space
as they could not avoid obstacles
this made space travel often deadly the
emergence of the guild was so
significant in the revitalization of the
declining empire
that their calendar was reset after its
formation
the time before the guild was given the
epoch bg
before guilt and ag
after guilt
beyond this without the ability to move
freely throughout the universe a
civilization becomes vulnerable in other
ways
sixth and low's remembrance of earth's
trilogy depicts the human race's
struggle to acquire faster than light
travel
in the books you see the helplessness of
a civilization without the ability to
move efficiently throughout the cosmos
in a universe potentially populated with
billions of other civilizations the
danger extends greatly without the
ability to escape enemies and natural
disasters the species is a sitting duck
among piranhas
in some series such as hyperion there
are certain issues associated with
specific kinds of space travel
in normal space travel relativity has to
be considered
this all of course relates back to
einstein's famous equation e equals m c
squared
time moves slower for those traveling
through the vacuum of space
at near light speed than for those
stationary on planets
a traveler may find that after returning
from a voyage off world that their loved
ones have died or aged beyond
recognition
even if you could solve these problems
and actually manage to get a galactic
society functioning
then comes the question of leadership
regulation and bureaucracy
and all of these have various issues
that can be associated with them just
stretched out to a galactic scale
on earth human civilizations often
gravitated to a model of centralized
leadership
organized in pyramid fashion with the
most valuable and most powerful at the
top
a major problem however arises when this
style of governance is applied to
galactic society
the more a cosmic civilization grows the
harder it becomes for centralized
government to handle its bureaucratic
and regulatory demands
in asimov's foundation series this is
the key cause for the fall of the empire
in the series the capital world tran
tour had long been the center of
imperial administration
the demands of such a large empire
proved to be too much for a centralized
style of leadership
the collapse of the entire system began
with trantor and when it fell the empire
fell
in a galactic empire led this way some
worlds and people would inevitably be
neglected
and because certain worlds would be
given more attention than others this
would lead to problems of inequality
throughout the inhabited universe
this would ultimately weaken the unity
of any galactic empire as humankind's
baseline sense of inherent equality
would be destroyed
because of this resentment towards the
centralized ruling class would no doubt
increase
this would lead to rebellions inevitably
ensuing
these rebellions would also threaten the
stability of the empire on a galactic
scale these problems compound upon each
other until they are unmanageable
leaders incapable of managing the
problems arising from a growing empire
then often turn to cruel methods to
suppress rebels and to quell any
potential unrest in the future in turn
more often than not this simply makes
things worse increasing the resentment
towards the ruling class and it becomes
a vicious cycle that erodes the
integrity of the empire as a whole
frank herbert's dune saga also makes an
argument directly in opposition to the
idea of centralized leadership on a
galactic scale the main idea being if
one person could rule over all of
humanity then one threat could
annihilate it this highlights the
inherent threat of centralized
leadership on the cosmic stage the
magnifying effect that power and
influence has on the actions of certain
individuals is amplified
instead of an individual's actions
potentially affecting an entire country
the whole of humanity is affected
this was the effect with trantor in
asimov's series and the same principle
is also demonstrated in sixteen lewis
series with the concept of the wall
facers and later the sword holders
of course there are always workarounds
to these problems and many science
fiction series have shown examples still
often much of the conflict and driving
narratives of many science fiction
series are tied to the inherent problems
which arise when humanity attempts to
exist on a galactic scale and add that
to the fact that sci-fi empires are
often governed in an archaic manner
why does there need to be an emperor we
outgrew emperors on earth i hope why
would we have them in the future that's
going backwards
a functioning galactic society likely
wouldn't resemble any society on earth
because a new system of governance would
have to form in order to accommodate the
current state of human society
this video was of course brought to you
by my wonderful patrons if you would
like to support this channel please
click the patreon link in the
description
[Music]
foreign